My name is Pedro Reyes
and I am an artist.
I am the inaugural
Dasha Zhukova Distinguished
Artist in residency at MIT.
which is a residency for which
I made a project
called "Manufacturing Mischief"
which is a puppet show.
the play is part of
a project that I started
perhaps eleven years ago
working with puppets.
The advantage of using puppets
to talk about philosophy
is that you don't need
to delve too much into
the personality aspects of
the philosopher,
but you can go more
into the ideas.
[Chomsky] This is my point,
you cannot control the
mishaps of devices
that think for themselves.
This is a very exciting
new development
because it features
Noam Chomsky as the protagonist
And it has to do with
certain questions about
the moral dimensions
of technology.
[Chomsky] The way forward
isn't an unchecked
approach to technology
But think of the good we
could do professor
Some of the fears that one
may have about
the destruction of labor
due to automation,
or that often
technology eccelerates
the inequity gap,
or the blocks to
democracy because
of artificial intellegence, etc,
have been addressed
by Professor Chomsky
so it was a big
inspiration to use
some of his writings
to develop a play.
[Chomsky] Zyklon B
Fritz Haber
Polish Jew
won the Nobel Peace Prize
for creating cheap
nitrogen fertilizer.
[Student] See? I want to
help like that!
[Chomsky] And when the
Nazis got ahold of
his altruistic chemical
they pumped it into
the gas chambers
and killed
1.2 million people.
It is important
to take into
consideration that
technology doesn't have
a moral value
in itself.
It can be used
both for good
and for evil.
[♪]
The play is
a comedy.
Which is a format
that allows
us to address
all these
subjects in a
very lighthearted manor.
Puppets allow you
to break a lot of rules
It's a very forgiving medium
in the sense that
you can make
very silly encounters
In the case of
Manufacturing Mischief,
you have persons
from different moments
in history
that never had
the chance to
meet in real life
But they're coming
together, and
what is bringing
them together is
the Deus ex Machina
which is a machine
called the
Print-a-Friend.
You put a book
into the
Print-a-Friend
and out comes
the author.
It's like bringing
the author to life
No explanations are
given on how
this happens.
[Chomsky] Are you...?
Karl Marx?
[Student] Surprise!
All of these
characters start
to come back.
Karl Marx is one of them
Ayn Rand is another.
And even Trump
himself emerges
out of the
Print-a-Friend.
The play is
trying to remind
us about
the importance
for a human dimension
when it comes to
technology.
How important it is
to keep in mind
what are the social costs
that embracing a
technology will have.
[Student] Oh my god